der krieg in der ukraine hat gesichter
hat gesichter die hoffnung geben
wladimir klitschko nimmt uns alle mit in
diesen krieg immer wieder nimmt uns mit
in sein land obwohl er irgendwie für uns
auch teil unseres landes ist den krieg
den hat er kurz verlassen doch
sicherlich ist er im herzen mit ihm
mitgereist mit hierher ins sichere
berlin jetzt hier bei bild lei vladimir
klitschko und gemeinsam mit paul
ronzheimer der uns aus kiew zugeschaltet
ist sprechen wir jetzt mit ihm mit
vladimir klitschko schon gut mit und
schilderten abend schön dass sie bei uns
sind fünf wochen ganz genau ist es her
dass der krieg begonnen hatte sind sie
hier zum ersten mal in sicherheit fühlen
sie sich jetzt sicher was ist das für
ein gefühl
ich glaube das ist ein schlechter traum
ist dass man kurz zu diesem schlechten
traum
ausgestiegen ist wieder in berlin ist es
ist alles so bekannt und so gut und ganz
anders als in kiew
und ich realisiere gerade das ist kein
traum ist das ist ein trauma für die
menschen in der ukraine
ständig werden wir beschlossen bis 2000
raketen russ raketen aus weißrussland
und aus russland
sind abgeschossen wurden auch den
griechischen boden geladen sind
menschliches leben genommen
infrastruktur gestört wohnhäuser
zerstört
es ist
nicht mit worten zu beschreiben
was die ukraine und die ukraine gerade
erleben während wir reden wird weiter
beschossen in mariupol
und 90 prozent ist die stadt zerstört
1000 tausende zivilisten sind gestorben
kinder sind gestorben nie gestorben
gekillt worden von der russische armee
journalisten sind präzise die haben auch
auf ihren helm und schutzweste
press presse gehabt also
des journalisten gezielt mit
scharfschützen
angeschossen ungekühlt wurden weil man
will nicht dass die welt erlebt was
gerade in der ukraine passiert und die
russische propaganda verkauft eigenen
landsleuten belegt eigenen landsleuten
das ist die nationalität also die nazis
sollten in der ukraine sein wir haben
einen jüdischen also mit jüdischen
wurzeln präsident sind ins gehör es gibt
keine nazis in der ukraine
ich bin als halo cos memory
mitglied von the board und donners
das zu sehen was 19 41 über
100.000
unschuldige menschen von der laz
erschossen wurden und dann in 20 22 dort
wo das fernsehen
nun steht sind wieder
zivilisten gekillt worden und von wem
vorher ist dass das haller kostbares
also hall kos mit coolen das ist kost
mit russischen raketen gewesen von
russischer kehrten sie in die zivilisten
gestorben genau dem platz wo 41 schon
wieder nicht schon wieder aber da meist
es angefangen hat und jetzt schon wieder
menschliches leben verloren gegangen da
fragt man sich wer sind die nazis wer
für diese politik und bringt die
unschuldige menschen um
russland mit jeremy russischen panzern
russische soldaten und die führung herrn
putin präsident denn beauftragt hat die
ukraine anzugreifen inmitten dieses
krieges all dieser schrecklichen bilder
hören wir immer wieder ihre klaren worte
auch eben auf deutsch das hilft uns noch
besser diesen krieg zu verstehen ihn uns
noch näher zu bringen aber wir sehen sie
auch immer wieder an der seite ihres
bruders sie diese fühlen diese männer
mit diesem breiten schultern das hat
auch immer etwas tröstendes dass wir sie
gemeinsam sehen die beiden brüder seite
an seite jetzt haben sie sich für ein
paar tage voneinander getrennt nach so
langer zeit noch so intensiven
schrecklichen erlebnissen wie fühlt sich
das an in diesen momenten ohne den
bruder plötzlich
wissen sie ich habe verstanden dass sich
nicht nur die denn bruder sondern die
bruder und die schwester da sind meine
landsmänner und frauen ich bin stolz
auf unsere leute ich bin stolz auf
unsere frauen die
schulter zu schultern mit waffen stehen
mit den männern verteidigen entweder
integrale verteidigung oder in armee
verteidigen eigenes land
verteidigen eigene familien häuser
eigene kinder
es ist
wie gesagt nicht mit worten zu
beschreiben weil man kennt einander zwar
nicht aber man weiß wir haben eine
verbindung miteinander
ohne was zu sagen wir haben ein ziel wir
haben ein gefühl die liebe zum eigenen
land wir haben einen einen feind der uns
angegriffen hat
frey gern gegriffen hat wir waren
niemals dafür vorbereitet weil wir haben
niemals klare vision gezeigt oder
jemandem angegriffen um so feige
anzugreifen so uns zu wählen und zu
stören das ist ghana zieht des
ukrainischen volkes was gerade passiert
ich kann das nicht miteinander worten
nennen aber als genozid
weil wie gesagt wir haben das recht
nicht zu entscheiden in welchem land
wollen wir leben mit welchen werten
wollen wir leben wir haben entschieden
2014 und das war klar und deutlich und
wir gehen diesen weg
uns ist nicht zu stoppen außer wir
müssen alle
gekühlt werden alle
wir mit unserem willen
stärker als die waffen oder eine andere
stärksten armee der welt
aber alles hat ein leben alles hat einen
anfang und ein ende
ich möchte
dass unsere partner
das ende dieser vision von russland in
die gründe werden weil wir sitzen gerade
in geleen
im ehemaligen ddr ich schließe nicht aus
dass appetit kommt weil es während des
essens und die propaganda die russische
propaganda diese giftige propaganda die
bringen die menschen um wie
eine waffe hat schon angekündigt ukraine
ist nur der anfang wir werden weiter
rollen wie weit diese imperialismus
rollen wird
es sieht weiter holen wenn wir nicht
mehr da stehen die ukraine
gegen den feind ist jetzt weiter geholt
ich möchte dass diese krieg so schnell
wie möglich beendet wird ich möchte ihn
nicht mehr dass unschuldige leute
sterben hier in europa seit dem zweiten
weltkrieg gab es keinen bruch diese
internationale regelung und
unabhängigkeit den ländern und im
integration der grenzen
ich möchte dass unsere partner uns
hören ich möchte ein riesen dankeschön
sagen an die deutschen anders volk
auch eine politik weil er seit seit 2004
sind die größten unterstützer der
ukraine
aber auch entscheidet wie ukraine weiter
da stehen wird deutschland ist das kern
europas mit dieser freiheits werten die
man kritischen werten
wirtschaftliche stabilität
kreativität
disziplin
innovation und viel viel mehr ich möchte
dass deutschland auch für frieden steht
nicht nur für technologien für frieden
für frieden für welchen wir so stark
kämpfen wir geben nicht auf wir brauchen
nur eine unterstützung was fordern sie
konkret was fordern sie von deutschland
wie kann wie muss deutschland jetzt
helfen ukraine während des krieges
hat keine wirtschaft
die badges werden nicht aufgefüllt mit
steuern das heißt wir haben keine gelder
wir brauchen eine finanzielle
unterstützung
weil wie gesagt die wirtschaft schafft
das nicht wir brauchen
humanitäre unterstützung
weil manche städte haben kein strom
keine lebensmittel kein wasser
keine wärme ist es noch immer kalt bei
uns keine wärme
keine medizinische versorgung
nicht nur medikamenten wir haben nicht
mal
ärzte weil unsere krankenhäuser genauso
wie theater werden beschossen schulen
und kindergärten auch
kinder gehören nicht in die schule gehen
und den kindergarten die haben aktuell
keine zukunft deswegen brauchen wir jede
art und weise humanitäre unterstützung
und hilfe wir brauchen waffen
das ist ein thema wo man in deutschland
sagt vorsicht waffen
offensive oder defensive wo ist der
unterschied wer auch immer
militärisch gesprochen aber wir brauchen
das auch um uns zu verteidigen
mit fäusten schafft man das nicht man
braucht das mittel
mit der man uns gilt aber uns zu
schützen
uns zu schützen europa zu schützen die
welt zu schützen frieden zu schützen
dafür sind sie in diesen momenten in
diesen stunden und tagen hier in berlin
um das noch einmal mit einem charisma
und ihrem nachdruck hier zu sagen uns
allen uns deutschen der bundesregierung
auch mit uns in diesem gespräch ist paul
paul sagt uns einmal der dieser besuch
von vladimir der wird natürlich auch in
der ukraine mit ganz besonderem
interesse geschaut und es heißt dort man
hat sozusagen die ukrainische spezial
waffe jetzt noch mal nach berlin
geschickt
so ist es ich komme in diesem moment aus
den präsidenten gebäude und habe dort
andere jahrmarkt getroffen der ist der
chef der präsidialverwaltung der engste
berater von lotte messe lenski und ich
habe dort mit ihm ein interview führen
können und habe ihn gefragt diese
hoffnungen er hat in diese delegation
angeführt eben oder mit dabei von
wladimir klitschko und er sagte das ist
unsere spezial waffe wir wissen dass die
deutschen bleiben klitschko und vitali
klitschko so sehr lieben wir wissen dass
die große sympathie haben und offenbar
versucht man es jetzt mit einer art
charmeoffensive nämlich dadurch dass
wladimir klitschko in berlin ist dort
verschiedene minister trifft und das
anliegen der ukraine noch mal klarmacht
eins ist aber klar kein hier beim
präsidenten in der politischen stimmung
versteht man nicht warum deutschland
bislang weiter zögerlich ist was waffen
angeht man sich versteht auch nicht
warum deutschland zögerlich ist was gas
und öl embargo angeht und auch dass er
noch gesagt während wladimir klitschko
dort in deutschland ist und russland ja
behauptet hat man würde ja abziehen und
man würde einen teilabzug zumindest aus
der region machen ja man sieht es
teilweise aber man erlebt weiterhin dass
es angriffe gibt man erlebt explosionen
und vor allem erleben wir dass der krieg
im ganzen land massiv weiter geht und
dieses deutsche gefühle nacht dann
nehmen die vielleicht nur den osten und
dann bleibt ihr wenigstens frei was da
manche deutsche zumindestens mein gefühl
jetzt aufkommen das sorgt hier für
empörung wo die menschen sagen nein wir
wollen unser land verteidigen das ist
eine gewaltige verantwortung jetzt in
diesen stunden in diesen tagen für sie
in berlin gewaltige hoffnungen in der
heimat alle schauen auf sie was es hier
möglicherweise noch zu erreichen gibt
was wäre das maximum was ist das beste
was sie sich vorgenommen haben was sie
erreichen können in diesen tagen hier in
deutschland erklärt spruch wie gesagt
aus der ist der hand ich bin gerade aus
kiel gekommen
erstmal mitzukriegen wie wir in der
ukraine leben was passiert mit uns aus
dem ersten herren was brauchen wir aus
dem ersten rennen und es ist ganz
wichtig und ich verstehe ist ein sehr
komplexer prozess auch was politik
betrifft und auch was die entscheidungen
betrifft ist nimmt auch sehr viel zeit
man nennt das bürokratie aber
man hat das wenn man eine komplexe
strukturen system hat was den
demokratischen welt ist
trotz diesen die entscheidungen sollten
schneller getroffen werden wir haben die
zeit nicht werden wir diesen gespräch
führen gespräch führen es wird weiterhin
beschossen es wird weiter gilt es wird
weiter gekämpft es wird jetzt gerade
dunkle in kiew haben jetzt soll das
heißt das ist die zeit und er wieder die
angriffe jetzt während das gespräch ich
bin ganz sicher dass paul hat schon bei
explosion gehört es geht einfach weiter
wir haben keine zeit
zeitspiel genoss wir müssen agieren
gemeinsam
gemeinsam agieren und es ist ein ganz
wichtiger punkt meines besuches diese
unterstützung für die ukraine auf
politischer ebene ist unglaublich
wichtig mit daten nicht mit worten
ich will auch sagen wenn man ein
passiver beobachter ist
hat man auch
das blut
auf eigenen
passiv zu sein heißt mitzumachen
wegschauen heißt mitzumachen
es darf nicht sein dass diese frei wild
auf die man so sicher rentiert
auch denen die sich dafür entschieden
haben und auch ihre leben mit ihrem
leben bezahlen nicht mit euro
mit leben
im stich lassen
ich will hier nicht kritisieren aber ich
möchte die menschen motivieren nur
gemeinsam können wir schaffen da muss
man sich wirklich fragen
nicht was jemand für mich tun kann was
kann ich tun
ich möchte auch was versprechen
wir fragen viel nach die ukraine braucht
viel brauche ich nicht nachzählen
ich verspreche euch eine wir kämpfen
auch für ruhig in der ukraine und wir
geben euch mehrfach ziel von
allem vor allem auch mit dem leben
kreativität die ukraine sind eine
kreative nation gut ausgebildeten nation
die nicht nur woods appelliert hat
hubschrauber und
kostenträger flugzeuge der light
industrial
zerstört worden
wir können viel mehr
wir
geben euch viel mehr zurück deswegen
möchte ich fragen bitte unterstützen es
ist nie genug es ist wichtig dass jetzt
zu machen jetzt zu schaffen
wir machen unseren job unseren job
aber der boden in der ukraine
wir tun alles um den adresse zu stoppen
wir brauchen eure unterstützung bitte
nicht aufhören
diesen bewegenden worten ist kaum etwas
hinzuzufügen jetzt sind sie hier in
berlin paulus uns zugeschaltet aus kiew
und sicherlich wenn man so etwas erlebt
ein krieg der für uns alle hier dennoch
obwohl wir die bilder sehen jeden tag
dennoch so abstrakt bleibt sie erleben
den dort jeden tag sie sprechen mit den
menschen dort sie sind ein held sie sind
ein mensch der den menschen hoffnung
gibt für sie da ist dort bleibt obwohl
sie das überhaupt gar nicht müssten und
selig brennen sich auch in ihr herz
szenen ein die man niemals vergisst
welche szenen sind das was brennt sich
in ihr herz ein was passiert gerade in
ihren und was wir hier wissen ich bin
kein held
wenn deutschland
trotz halbiert
angegriffen wird ich bin fest davon
überzeugt wenn jemand durch zuhause
angreift
kind im mann oder ihre frau und ihre
kinder
nimmt alles weg für brände aus
glauben sie mir wir wollen genauso sein
sie werden für ihre recht
für das leben stehen so wie wir das in
dokumenten die helden sind die menschen
die frauen die ihren leben
für das land und freiheit abgegeben
haben und die männer die helden sind die
journalisten die trotzt
diese gefahren aus dem ausland aus der
serie genauso paul ronzheimer und viele
andere in der ukraine sind am ort sind
und berichten
aus der erste schuss linie mit ihrem
leben zu riskieren aber dass die will
genau weiß bescheid und sieht es nicht
nur mit worten mit bildern weil bilder
sprechen lauter würden die bleiben im
kopf viel länger hängen als das was
gesagt wird auch paul hat kollegen
verloren in dieser zeit haben sie
freunde enge freunde verloren im krieg
habe ich
damals immer die frage gestellt bleibt
dort in krieg überhaupt die möglichkeit
all diesen menschen eine beerdigung zu
geben abschied zu nehmen
ist es überhaupt möglich
sie können sich vorstellen
diese dritten städten
wird ihnen christoph
matschie
menschen liegen unter straßen
so wie die gilt wurden zivilisten
liegen auf den straßen
es gibt keine die sie begraben kann
keine weil über diesen minen geschosse
die leichen sind auch ein
mit mir lagen wir sind gefahren ohne
ende ihre pin kann immer noch nie
befreit werden nach ihnen ist es immer
noch gefährlich einzureisen trotz dass
die
sozusagen nie da ist aber es werden
immer ständig beschossen
es wird immer ständig beschossen und
noch einmal es ist nicht mit worten zu
beschreiben
es ist nur dass schrecken des krieges
was wir in westeuropa nur hören können
deswegen ich möchte dass die menschen
aktiv sind mit allem was man nun man
kann es ist 9 x
20 22 sowas durfte nie passieren und wir
das angefangen hat muss er sein
muss er sein
was wird man mit dem land machen wenn es
alles zerstört ist was mir wird man mit
atomkraftwerken machen und wir haben
fünf davon inklusive tschernobyl mit
mehrere reaktoren und eine davon ist im
foyer gewesen die sie 2003 ketten die
sind schon gelandet auf den boden wo ist
die garantie dass seine davon nicht
an die kraft für atomkraftwerken landet
was passiert dann sie können sich nicht
vorstellen
es ist eine gefahr für die welt für
tausende jahren und es wird fukushima
und tschernobyl
mehrfach deswegen diese krieg musik
stoppt muss während des werden es muss
passieren es muss jetzt passieren er mit
diesen tagen auch mit dem vize
bürgermeister den shows wohl nur die
flüchtlinge
es gibt nicht nur ukraine ist alle der
großen produzenten
fast das lebensmittel betrifft
getreide die sind an den größten die
ganze welt wird im hunde seien
es ist eine kettenreaktion
man denkt noch einmal ukraine ist nur
der name unter leben die menschen und
die man auch freundlich sein weil ich
schön aber wir auf diesen globalen welt
miteinander wahnsinnig stark verbunden
und wenn ein teil dieser kehrte er
ausfällt fehlt die komplette kette
auseinander neben die tage weil sie auch
mario pohl und die satellitenstädte auch
vor kirche angesprochen haben aber eben
auch mario pohl werden mit dem vize
bürgermeister in diesen tagen gesprochen
hat einen satz gesagt nicht nur dass die
menschen dort die letzten menschen die
dort noch ausgeharrt haben marie pohl
wie mäuse leben so hat er das formuliert
sondern auch dass sein eigenes herz
seine eigene seele eingefroren sei
stellen sie sich stellen sie das an sich
auch fest das herz eingefroren in diesen
tagen weil man nichts mehr spürt
ich habe nie so viel erlebt wie die
menschen in europa es ist viel
schrecklicher viel schlimmer viel
brutaler
das nur was man nur mit krieg es ist
die menschen die mit waffen
zu die zivilisten tun
es hat nichts mit menschen zu tun und
das passiert fast jedem krieg so dass
wegen krieg so brutal
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen ich das
nicht sagen dass ich mir vorstellen kann
keine von musik an das vorstellen was
für mario gollob keine die haben keinen
strom die haben kein wasser die haben
kein essen die haben nun die chance
die haben nur toten körper um sich keine
pause es ist ich wollte eine geschichte
schreiben wird etwas grobkörnig wenn er
passiert mit dem rechten aber um einen
kompletten was einmal mitzunehmen gerade
in diesem moment
ja gerade in diesem moment hier ein
einschlag im zentrum also riesige
explosion wir haben sie reden gehört
also um das in diesem moment mitzunehmen
merkt von wegen frieden von wegen
wladimir putin sich hier seine truppen
zurück also relativ zentrums nachgerade
ein einschlag in diesen minuten
das ist die realität hingehe gerade
wissen sie das sind sie immer
minutengenau über die lage informiert
kriegen sie warnungen möglicherweise
auch haben sie dann noch irgendwie ein
paar sekunden zeit in kiew wieder in den
bunker zu gehen
ich habe keinen bunker
mann
es ist es ist wahrscheinlich schwer zu
verstehen man gewöhnt sich an die
explosionen man gewöhnt sich an gefahren
man gewöhnt sich daran dass
auch
seine freunde verwandten du selbst
betroffen sein kannst man rechnet mit
allem mit mit allem jeden der
ukrainischen boden heute zu tage ist
muss damit rechnen dass er gewillt sei
nicht das spielt keine rolle bist du ein
kind ein journalist oder
jemand anderes
es ist es ist
wie gesagt es ist nicht mit worten zu
beschreiben und glauben sie mir es ist
schwer zu verstehen wenn man täglich
alter kann man kommt dann morgens und
job die kinder wären dann ins
kindergarten gebracht ob in die schule
man kriegt sein frühstück man kann ganz
ruhig schlafen
man kann auch was plant für nächsten
drei tagen und am wochenende oder eltern
besuchen kinder besuchen großeltern
besuchen mit dem fahrzeug einfach
umfahren das hat man nicht und die queen
ist nicht so weit wie irene noch unseren
die schöne bilder von
eurovision song contest und dem
champions league finale oder euro cup
2012 und die blühende ukraine die
freundliche menschen die die welt zu
sich zu gast gehabt haben gestern gehabt
haben es ist leider nicht mehr existent
es ist nicht mehr existent
es ist nur leid nur schrecken
und ist dort ist nicht laut
das
darf man
nicht erleben das muss nicht passieren
das darf nicht passieren
deswegen möchte ich noch einmal jungs
gute rolle
wir müssen diesen krieg stoppen
wir müssen es tun wir müssen diesen
diktator stoppen wir müssen es tun
wir werden
auch diese opfer dieses krieges seien
ohne ausnahmen deswegen muss
in europa wie der frieden seien das
internationale recht muss wieder
zugreifen
alle müssen an diesen rechtssicher
rentieren
es kann nicht sein dass
menschen
werden einfach so asche gebracht um
gemacht
menschen die das nicht verdient haben
menschen die keinen was böses getan
haben um das land
hat nicht den krieg angefangen
das land
braucht unterstützung und ich möchte
gerne dass wir diese unterstützung
bekommen deswegen bin ich in berlin
heute kurzfristig es war eine schwere
entscheidung für mich einzureisen
aber ich muss es tun
für die menschen die kräne für das land
und nicht du wirklich alles was ich noch
tun kann und nicht ich möchte trotz dass
sie immer nach wie vor sagen wir
brauchen immer mehr aber danke
an die deutsche bevölkerung
danke an europäische länder an unserer
partner dass wir diese unterstützung
bekommen ja wir brauchen mehr und wir
beschweren uns das ist nie genug ist es
wirklich nie genug glauben sie wenn sie
um leben und tod und wenn es um leben
und tod entschieden wird es ist nie
genug ist marina wir brauchen mehr
wir brauchen mehr brauchen jetzt wir
haben keine zeit
jetzt gehen sie in einigen stunden
wahrscheinlich erst schlafen in berlin
plötzlich und nicht in kiew glauben sie
dass sie immer weiter alarm hören werden
in ihren ohren in ihrem kopf immer
weiter explosionen hören werden oder
glauben sie dass sie zum ersten mal seit
langem schlafen können
man bildet sich ein aber man halte
ständig wenn man das
für 30 tage geld hat man hört es
jedes geräusch erinnert dich ein
geschoss von eine waffe oder eine bombe
und gewiss ist zwar dran aber natürlich
manchmal das ständig
ständig und vor allem
man hat die bilder den menschen die ihr
zuhause verloren haben die ihre
familienmitglieder verloren haben kinder
verloren haben
und die sie brauchen nichts
die müssten nun ihre land verteidigen
die brauchen waffen um sich zu
verteidigen nicht das nächste kind der
letzte denn man hat
verliert oder die kinder es gibt keine
fremde kinder das habe schon gesagt bei
ein herz für kinder
kinder sind ihren diesen alle gleich in
jedem land egal welche sprache gespräche
wo der hautfarbe haben kinder haben
gleiche spielzeuge gleich interessen
kinder wollen welt erleben nicht dass
krieg erleben die kinder in der ukraine
erleben krieg
500 davon sind getötet und verletzt
wurden
die werden nie diesen krieg vergessen
nie
im leben ein leben
die kinder dieses krieges auch kinder
die geboren werden jetzt die in diesem
krieg hineingeboren werden die diese
diesem krieg ins leben starten wir haben
auch die bilder gesehen von paul
ronzheimer der uns noch zugeschaltet ist
jetzt gerade live aus kiew von menschen
die zuflucht suchen in bunkern unten in
den krankenhäusern und niemand geht wenn
er so etwas erleben muss als der gleiche
mensch der vorher war weiter ins leben
sind sie ein anderer mann geworden durch
diesen krieg ja
es ist das leben vor dem krieg
und ich vor dem krieg um ich während des
kriegs ich kann dir sagen nach dem krieg
während des kriegs das hat jeden fremden
ohne ausnahmen in der ukraine jeden
verändert ganz anders
manche weniger die anderen die
diesen horror erlebt haben noch mehr
die erwachsenen die erleben dass auf
jeder art und weise jugendliche und die
fahrt ans herz angeschossen wurden vor
seine augen um er selbst direkt danach
von kugeln getroffen wurden
die 14 jährige junge und
davon berichtet wird
und weil er an so einer kapuze gehabt
hat und es zu boden gefallen ist dann
angetroffen wurden schulter und dann hat
zwei geschoss am kopf bekommen so dachte
er der russische soldat hat da wohl
seine kapuze getroffen
er wird nie mehr
der junge sein der vor dem krieg war und
das sind viele beispiele die grauen
haben sind
und das nicht mit worten zu beschreiben
deswegen ich möchte mich bedanken bei
bei euch dass er davon berichtet
ich möchte dass deutschland nicht erlebt
aber ich möchte dass deutschland weiter
unterstützt mehr unterstützt
gemeinsam kriegen wir sehen gemeinsam
stoppen wäre der größe gemeinsam wenn
wir wieder frieden haben in der ukraine
das ist nicht weiter kommt und in europa
gemeinsam für ein reh die ukraine wieder
aufbauen allein schaffen wäre das nicht
ich hoffe und ich wünsche dass die
zeiten schnelle kommt dass man bei
aufbau berhaupt sprechen kann und
nachkriegszeiten und wir absprechen kann
aber ist eine eine komplett schwierige
kehrte weil das ganze land ist mit minen
geschossen die nicht explodiert sind
belegt und diese ruhe wird man noch sehr
sehr lange auch nach dem glück nie nie
mehr haben
ganz viele ihrer menschen sind bei uns
kinder frauen mittlerweile
hunderttausende die wir aufnehmen wollen
das ist auch etwas was zu unserer
unterstützung gehört auch das was können
sie all diesen kindern sagen hier bei
uns im land aus der ukraine
wollen sie dass die ganz schnell deutsch
lernen dass die ganz schnell hier zur
schule gehen ganz schnell sich
integrieren das sind doch all die kinder
und all die frauen die sie möglichst
schnell wieder bei sich haben wollen in
der ukraine
wissen sie was die kinder wollen ich
weiß es nach hause
so einfach wie es ist die wollen nach
hause welt da sind ihre
lieblingsspielzeuge
das sind wir freunde die denken so dass
sie zu hause
wo sie ihre erste begeisterung gelebt
haben in den wänden aber die wissen
nicht und die verstehen nicht und das
weiß ich dass das hat zu hause nicht
existiert das leben was sie davor gehabt
haben gibt es nicht mehr
ich weiß was die kinder holen
die wohnung
in der heimat natürlich bedanken
die familien
dass deutschland so viele flüchtlinge
schon aufgenommen hatte
das kann man aber nicht ersetzen das
zuhause gefühl
die stadt
das dorf
wo man aufgewachsen ist wo man das so
stark lebt die sprache
auch ein thema und viel mehr
und deswegen nicht weiß was sie können
dabei auch die wohnung nach hause
deswegen müssen wir schnellstmöglich
verdienen schaffen und es gibt mehrere
schritte dafür und wir mussten da
durchgehen
der weg ist steinig und schwer aber wir
kriegen es hin wenn wir als
gemeinschaft
agieren reagieren
auf diese schneemann brutale tat diesen
krieg
diese creek durfte nicht passieren
wir haben viel verschlafen
seit 2014
also das internationale recht gebrochen
wurden mit den aktien von cream als im
osten der ukraine krieg herrschte
mit sogenannten separatisten die
rettungsschirme mit dem segment
unterstützt worden
die freie welt hat viel zu lang
nice gewesen
viel zu lernen konnte schätzt viel zu
lang geglaubt an das lügen
und auch dass
kein europäisches land angegriffen wird
ist lügen
das lügen darf nicht weiterkommen
es muss ein ende haben und das handy
muss in der ukraine passieren für den
jugend für das leben deswegen
dann können die deutschen
danke dass er unsere kinder aufgenommen
haben familien aufgenommen haben dass
sie hier schutz haben
ich möchte auch ich bin hier beim bild
er will ich zu so es ist
die wahrheit
die wahrheit bleibt am lenken
und das lügen
wird keine zukunft haben deswegen weiter
berichten
dank an alle journalisten dann kennt
paul dann kein zuschauer dass anna lisa
an unterstützer
danke
und wie gesagt das ist leider nicht
genug der klitschko ist es kaum
auszuhalten wenn sie uns den dank geben
wir geben ihnen den dank dass sie hier
sind und dass sie diese kraft aufbringen
diese zuversicht in dieser unglaublichen
phase ihres lebens mitten in diesem
krieg es ist fast nicht auszuhalten
diese stärke von ihnen zu spüren hier in
diesem studio die sie uns geben ihrem
volk aber vor allem nicht geben ihren
menschen kiew geben im bruder ihrer
familie geben und allen im moment am
bildschirm
wir danken ihm dass sie hier waren danke
paul
[Musik]